welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the podcast that gives
you too much information about the
mandalorian's weird
refusal to never take off his helmet is
it the way to eat lunch alone in a
bathroom stall where no one can see your
face
i hope so because that that's how we did
it right joven we got juvent back this
week
it is what we did in fact even my short
stint as a homeschool
kid i wanted to be eating my lunch in
the bathroom because it was my safe
space
hey there's something about it just
feels like ah no one will disturb me in
here or judge
how i eat my food with my fingers i
don't believe in forks
because we're medieval times boys
pudding cup no spoon for me good sir
oh god i will chug this mott's
applesauce thank you
well jovan we're talking star wars this
week and we know star wars is in your
dna we had to get you on to talk about
this with us you know being here on new
rockstars i've talked a lot of marvel
a little bit of dc and not enough star
wars so
it's good to flex those those mind
muscles now you'll get a chance to flex
your muscles
of your mind this week because our big
question is why do some
mandalorians like den jiren on the
mandalorian always wear his helmet
religiously
while other mandalorians from the star
wars animated series that we've seen
don't really care about that kind of
thing what's the deal with the helmet
we've been
asking this question a lot and let's
dive deep into it
and see what it means for the next
season of the mandalore i think the
first thing that we have to do is
immediately
write off the fact that this was on
accident or a plot hole
because i know in the sequel trilogies
there's a lot of times where you know
maybe there wasn't a lot of forethought
as they were going into some of the
story but
because the mandalorian had dave filoni
as an ep
on it who was also the creative star
wars rebels and the clone wars along
with george
lucas on that he was on both projects we
have to assume that
no this was not an accident and not a
plot hole
right it's the same people working on
both this is one of the rare examples in
in the star wars universe where like
there's no interlopers who are changing
the story or anything
favro very much defers to filoni's
vision and understanding of what is star
wars canon
when you look at star wars rebels which
has a lot of uh mandalore characters in
it
um and then obviously years later as the
mandalorian it takes place after episode
six
one might imagine that in star wars
rebels where you have characters from
mandalore who don't have their masks on
maybe there's something that happens in
between
star wars rebels and the men alone tv
show and we hear in the mandalorian them
talk about the great
purge quite a few times not a lot is
known about that particular event
but maybe after the the great purge or
because the great purge this is where
they wound up having this mandate that
masks stay on it was their coven 19
pandemic
empire came in and they're like guys if
you're going to go outside masks on
and just to be clear what we know about
this great purge uh moff gideon called
it the the night of a thousand tears
it's not the same thing as the siege of
mandalore it's a
that was a different event there's been
a bunch of sieges over the years but
mandalore has not been a great place to
right no not at all uh a lot of people
are conflating it mistakenly with the uh
the siege that we saw in the final
season of the clone wars right like
that was a republic siege when maul had
taken over the planet
this is another event that has not been
depicted on screen anywhere yet i would
imagine we're gonna see a lot more of in
season two which only time can tell
the whole creed of like this is the way
that did come from the purge
however when we talk about maybe there's
something that happened from the events
of
rebels to mandalorian that maybe someone
happened that's why they have masks on
we have to also see the flashbacks there
for
amanda himself that when he was a child
during the clone wars because we see the
super battle droids
when he was younger during the clone
wars he wasn't wearing a mask then
because he
he says specifically that he hasn't been
seen without his mask since
childhood so right that kind of rules
out the idea that it was something that
happened during the great purge
because you know he was already wearing
a mask at that time so you're saying
that it had to do
something before the great purge it must
have been during his training as a
foundling
this particular group of mandalorians
that he was with made that a thing
that just lived on yes i think with the
information that has been put out there
for us i think it's pretty safe to
assume that it wasn't just something
that wound up occurring
after the fact that upon him
joining is like this is the way so
we've got a lot of information out there
let's look at some of the stuff that we
do
know uh as we've stated before you have
characters like sabine wren
who are mandalorian but they do not
always wear their helmets
in star wars rebels we see characters
without their masks all the time now
mando only removes his helmet when he is
alone which is you know how he eats i
don't think he's like taking like
sandwich pieces and like putting
under his helmet to try to eat smearing
so much on his chin
he's like oh i got a little taste of it
this time yes we do know that they're
kind of hardcore about taking off the
mask because if they do take their masks
off
in front of someone they are not allowed
to ever
put it back on so the stakes are pretty
high for them
i think one of the questions that i'm
looking forward to be answered the most
in season two is with boba fett showing
up like django fed didn't always have
his mask on but
that did always have his mask on so i'm
thinking we're gonna see him without his
mask in season two and
i think this is where we're gonna find
out precisely why he's allowed to take
his mask off whether he's not actually
uh mandalorian and he's just like oh do
what i want to do or if there actually
is some war that we're missing
yeah you know what's interesting is like
um we know that boba fett
is uh is a clone of jenga vet um and
there seems to be some kind of
appropriation which is a big thing with
the mandalorian people they hate it when
other people are showing up wearing
their armor and it's like their designs
are specific to them and this particular
clan of mandalorians seems really
extreme about it
but it is interesting you kind of think
that's a story thematically
the people at lucasfilm definitely were
taking that idea of boba fett always
under the mask
and that appeal and applied it to the
mandalorian as a character even
it may be something that is canonically
linked or maybe just something that's
thematically linked but either way it's
a parallel that it's going to probably
be explored
and again looking at how serious the
mandalorians are about not taking off
their masks even when
petrol gaskets character is dying of a
head wound
right he tells ig 11's like i can't take
it off like in front of any living
creature of course we hear that and we
know what
poophole loopholes coming up he's an ig
11's like
dude i'm not a living thing so take off
your helmet so i can not kill you here
right now
or not let you die essentially
we get how fundamentally
serious that they are about not removing
their armor even when we see like a
spark of a love story he's like nope
helmet stays on lady so i also would
like to mention that i
it kind of is implied that that the
helmets do stay on even
during sex he could have had his little
romance subplot there at the end just
you know
no face stuff little guy gets a helmet
big guy gets a helmet
i think it's an excuse on his part so he
doesn't have to perform anything oral
it's a cheap loophole that's a poophole
loophole if i've ever
heard it yeah he's the dj khaled of the
star wars universe
but on a more serious note uh like i was
saying there there are some
real world implications that we can kind
of uh pull from
where i think that filoni and favreau
kind of pulled inspiration from
and i think the strongest being is that
we have a lot of different religious
practices
here on our earth where you know there
are
garments that are worn whether in public
or
always worn or just worn during prayers
for example muslim women
wearing the hijab jewish men are wearing
uh kippahs
and like it's it's a way of life for
them it's what they're supposed to do
it's part of their religion and you know
it's
it's unwavering it's unquestioned it's
just what you do so i think it's very
clear to see that the mandalorians have
some kind of whether it's a religion for
them or not
it comes from like a religious
background for the inspiration of it
yeah it's a ritual i don't know if
there's any kind of um
ecclesiastic connection to it where they
it's some kind of cosmic reason why they
do it based off of their who they
what they worship who they worship but
it is definitely a ritual
i think even in non-canon star wars lore
i don't
know if we've actually seen or heard of
any mandalorian
um deities or what gods they worship
obviously there's the mythosaur
right that's where the symbol comes from
but i i don't necessarily think that
they saw that as like a god it was just
like that's the biggest thing we can
hunt
so yeah they're they're more of a uh a
warrior class uh
like they seem more spartan inspired
rather than anything else
do you think they have abs like butler
did in uh 300.
hey we can find out because it's just
facial coverings yeah
about torso so let's see that mando
six-pack there's just a little window
for the for the six-pack just to show um
it's like the power girl outfit but just
like five inches lower
now at the same time that it only kind
of explains why
they have to put it on not necessarily
why it's so horrible for them to take it
off and i think that's where we
really get into the meat and potatoes of
of the mandalorian lore and why they
cannot take off the mask is because of
the reasons
why it's bad for them like you were
saying it's more like you know
like uh spartans and and i think that
yes when you're looking at
the design of the mandalorian lore the
amanda loren
uh i think that you have to look at a
religious aspect but you also have to
look at
military and like the warrior creed
behind it all
and that's very different from from like
a background religion but at the same
time there's just
some things that are so fundamentally
true that even as like a warrior like
you are
whether it's it's brainwashed into your
mind or just like this is our code we
stick to it which is
obviously we see a lot of that in the
show now the way
of the mandalorian is not necessarily a
religion they don't describe describe it
as a religion in the show
but a creed
he calls it the creed that's what we
hold we all say it online all the time
every chance we get like this is the way
so they have like their common values
and this is where you really see
a lot of like what makes the mandalorian
a mandalorian
when you look at like real life um
places where they could can pull from
uh obviously knights have a very strong
code of conduct
a lot of this of the star wars universe
is
built on samurai inspiration
so it makes a lot of sense that favreau
and filoni
who've worked with george lucas very
closely on this would also pull from
samurai origins
and with the samurai they had their code
they stuck to the code it was their life
or death
they did something wrong well it was
death and in that case we see
the drastic nature of the samurai code
versus the drastic nature of the
mandalorian code where it's like you
take this off
you're not putting it back on your life
has no meaning now after you take that
mask
and definitely the samurai origins might
be something that a lot of people say
got lost from the star wars universe as
it went on
and it was absolutely there the origins
of the jedi knights even
the word jedi has as origins and
japanese folklore but specifically
what people loved about the mandalorian
when it came out is it felt like
uh wolf and cub right like it felt like
these kind of
these uh samurai tales yeah it was so
refreshing it feels like a restoration
in a lot of ways and when you also look
at like
you've got the code of samurai and the
code of the mandalorian but let's also
look at like
the mentality behind it uh i think we
can kind of
pull from uh game of thrones to describe
this you have the unsullied
where um you have like these these
behaviors and the rules that you're
supposed to follow
and it really enforces an
anti-individualist
way of of being so it makes it easier to
maybe control your warriors or just see
yourself as
one of many and your life in the battle
doesn't necessarily matter
just that your team wins a very strong
connection
there and for a lot of uh people in
these uh
in military culture and extremist
religious cultures uh that have these
kind of rituals that they maintain it's
it's not just about like restriction and
discipline
it's about like preserving something
that is core to your identity
and the identity of your people you know
that otherwise if you just water down
it'll get lost
to as everything just gets lost in
history that certain
traditions are valuable uh to hold on to
just because it it links us to our past
right
and speaking of which man i hope they
tap into this next part
in a big way in season two but we
understand that
they have found links so you find these
um i guess
normally younger individuals so that
they can bring into
their mandalorian army and in order to
kind of take away
their individual identity you put them
in masks so that they can learn that
from where you're from doesn't really
matter but like this is the group that
you're with
i think that there's a a lot of
backgrounds in
brainwashing of you know militant groups
but also in the star wars universe
look at the jedi they're always pulling
these young things in
and you know you're not allowed to like
miss your your parents
your thoughts dwell on your mother no
[ __ ]
it's all about you're a jedi now this is
your way of life this is your way of
living
so it's already something that's pretty
common in the star wars universe
and man when you say those words out
loud you just reminded me the jedi
maybe not the good guys maybe not
depending on how
true like this idea is that you know
foundlings you get your helmet to lose
your identity to become a mandalorian
does that mean in season two we are
gonna get the most
adorable version of the child where he
has to be wearing
a helmet a tiny little helmet and little
because he's
partnered up now officially with the
mando so
i'm dressed like dad i'm a little darth
vader he just wears a darth vader mask
we're like no no no no no no
no but like my question uh eric is do
you
think for the conversations like baby
yoda uh with his mask
is it like just like do his ears like
have little slots that they hang out
i hope so yeah is it like a front and
back mask
just kind of like comes on like darth
vader's mask
ears are also have that baskar cover oh
the best scar
ear molds that'd be insane don't protect
the ears right
or tuck them you fold them back a little
bit
it just ties them like a little top bun
hey yeah because the the kids who have
the pokey ears when they play baseball
you got to wear your batter's helmet
they don't let your ears stick out you
just gotta
you got to tuck them in or surgically
take them in a little bit that's you
know just a little little nip a little
tuck
you're good to go here's my call to
action to the uh the new rockstars fan
base i know some of you have some
artistic ability
uh i need i would love to see the fan
art of the child
but with the mask on so uh please send
that right now we've been focusing a lot
on like the history or the lore that's
there for these characters on why they
have to wear the masks
i think that there's also some really
strong practical reasons just for
warfare that makes sense for them to
wear their masks at all times yeah
you had a whole group of mandalorians
that were like hiding underground
but we heard lines of dialogue in that
first episode where it's like
haven't seen your kind it's pretty rare
to see your kind and like three scenes
later we're like what are you talking
about
they're all down there right now they're
very sneaky very sneaky very sneaky i am
very very sneaky sir
but i think by having to wear a mask at
all times it it's
their way of masking their numbers uh
tuscan raiders
walking in a straight line to mask their
numbers mandalorians wearing masks
because if there's only one out at a
time and you never see their face
you don't know like all right which you
know okay there's only one of them
walking around
whether you see like all right there's
this guy and here's bob and then steve's
over there it's like all right
apparently there's more than one guy
yeah you'd have to mark them be like all
right i've
seen this one is that the same tree we
just passed by that same mandalorian
two hours ago and that's why in episode
three of the mandalorian their ambush
was so effective because
yeah no one knew how many there were
in their strong numbers now
unfortunately once they came out that's
like okay
gotta find a new place to live because
they now know here there's way too many
of us
but i think by having everyone wear
their helmets it's just almost
impossible for people to guess how many
were out there or even just out in the
universe outside
you know maybe some some armor designs
or collar
variants it could just be the same guy
with a lot of different armor
yeah that's true he's always changing
yeah it also
makes you wonder i bet a lot of people
don't know that they have that creed
because that farmer woman asked him
about it and she didn't know
so i you have to assume most people
don't know that they're never allowed to
take off their helmets
which do you think has like more clout
in the universe the jedi or the
mandalorians because like you know
there's a lot of people that don't
believe that the jedi even existed
we see like in just episode four just 18
years after
the last prequel movie like not everyone
in the galaxy believes in jedi or
thinks that they're a real thing yet
i've flown from one side of this galaxy
to the other i've seen a lot of strange
stuff but i've never seen
anything to make me believe there's one
all-powerful force controlling
everything yeah it's it is one crazy
thing that the star wars universe has
never truly justified in my opinion this
idea that like communication is so
shitty and star wars uterus they don't
have a simple internet that they can
just like look up
information their their dissemination of
news
is very spotty so like light swords and
1970s technology yeah but uh not enough
to pick up a phone
if an entire cult that had uh influence
over
the the senate was suddenly accused of
being the conspirators who are
trying to stage a coup a couple years
later they can be wiped off the face of
the universe and no one would even know
they ever existed like i don't care
how wide the infinite galaxy is
when someone blows up a planet i i think
you kind of believe
like the reasoning behind it and like
who some of the characters were
and yeah an entire galactic senate
had like you know the jedi behind them
now they're a myth
do we think that the mandalorian legend
is has a stronger
history throughout the galaxy that's a
good point i would say yeah
in the broader history i mean we've been
focused laser focused on the skywalker
saga in the history of the jedi
but that uh was really happening i mean
of course the jedi are ancient
but there's really like a small cult
that is
pretty exclusive and pretty like
closeted
i would say they're diplomats but
they're also knights if we compare that
to the english knights of the round
table right like it's a small group as
opposed to mandalore
it's an entire planet that has like
these spartans
so it's like the difference between the
knights templar and the spartans
yeah i don't know history buffs know
both and before episode one like jedi
again aren't supposed to be like
warriors they're they they're keepers of
the peace and let's let's be real
a war hero story goes a lot further than
you know uh
protector of peace so a mandalorian
warrior like
hell yeah i heard about jango fett that
guy kills like a bunch of people
like i i think that story just goes
around like from spaceport to spacex
a lot more effectively than the jedi i
think the reason this question comes up
so much
is a lot of the people who are into the
mandalorian are people who watch clone
wars
and uh star wars rebels and in their
minds
that is the new lore the new canon lore
of the mandalorian history and anything
outside of that
just doesn't exist so what i think
people don't appreciate is the fact that
the mandalorian is
adding it is retconning certain specific
things about this gap period
that we just didn't have any information
about we assumed no history happened
but they're saying there is a whole
other history
with this one particular group of
mandalorians it looks like they might
have been death watch associated but we
also know
death watch members did not uh worry
about keeping their helmets on or off
but like whatever this particular group
is the way they raised mando
was very very strict about it and that
is one of the few groups that survived
whatever that great purge was
we suppose and that might be why they
survived the great
right yeah i think it's very safe to
not necessarily assume but just like
based on the information that's given to
us like i think it's more fact that
these these characters in this group
in this creed is just like this separate
sect it's their own religious group so
like the death watch was like a separate
group with their own
ideologies and their own rules in their
own ways i think that the
ruling of keeping your mask on as a
mandalorian is really just
for this group not knowing we don't know
how big this group is
like they're just you know they're the
real warriors of of the mandolin the old
school warriors they're what's left
they're they're what has survived i mean
it seems like um
bringing in characters like bo katan and
uh sabine wren
in season two hopefully will shed some
light because they are mandalorian
characters
or you know characters linked with that
mandalorian history who didn't have a
problem keeping their helmets off i i
think that conversation is going to be
happening in these episodes
as you were pointing out with the
religious and military connections from
our real world
we we kind of instinctively get this i
think general audiences who don't really
know star wars rebels or clone wars they
watch that and they kind of get it
they're like yeah i mean
i know there's like military you know
rituals that they're pretty strict about
and
i don't think they really question it
it's really only people who saw clone
wars and rebels who were confused by
this
and uh you know the moment juan carlos
esposito took out his dark saber and
then the internet went
oh my god
but every like casual fan of star wars
was like
what is that why why am i supposed to
care about this
that's how you do good stories yeah see
a jedi yeah and then
now the nerds are important and now we
have something that we can actually
explain
i see your value now that's the nicest
thing anyone's ever said to me
but like any great reveal it brings up
more questions and answers because the
last time we saw that dark saber it was
in the hands of bo katan
we assumed that was like the end of that
chapter and that she would carry on the
mandalorian legacy for
for eons to come and uh i guess not
you know and i'm sure these things are
all linked i'm sure it's connected to
the great purge we've got some
flashbacks coming up oh yeah
oh yes all right we want to thank some
friends who helped us make this episode
a big question
starting with our friends at hero health
contractor no i will not bow to any
sponsor
it is hard to remember to take
medication my mind is already filled
with useless information about you know
don cheadle war machine memes boom are
you looking for this or mandalorian
history as we see this episode i don't
have the space up there to worry about
the schedule
of when exactly they need to take
medications and things like that well
hero
is your medicine cabinet reinvented the
hero pill dispenser
sorts all daily medications and delivers
them all with a push of a button
like if medication isn't taken the hero
app will send a notification to you or a
family member
a caregiver so a dose is never missed
hero makes it simple and easy to make
sure you or your loved ones stay
on track and you get the right meds at
the right time
every time your hero membership includes
the app the pill dispenser
and 24 7 support for just a dollar a day
hero even has an optional service that
delivers medication directly to your
door
never miss a dose again and always have
peace of mind with hero
right now if you go to herohealth.com
big question you'll get 50 off the
initiation fee
and a 30-day risk-free trial with money
back guaranteed
that is herohealth.com bigquestion to
start your membership with 50
off and a 30-day free trial don't forget
that zerohealth.com
big question we also want to thank our
friends and hello
fresh for sponsoring this episode maybe
i'm wrong on this one but for me the
beast doesn't include selling out
so hellofresh offers convenient delivery
right to your doorstep for easy home
cooking
their recipes are easy to follow and
quick to make with simple steps and
pictures to guide you along the way
they cut out stressful meal planning and
grocery store trips so you can just
enjoy cooking and get dinner on the
table in about 30 minutes
you could save 40 percent by using hello
fresh versus shopping at your local
grocery store
i really like how convenient hello fresh
meals are
like on a day when i'm really busy
writing and shooting videos it's just
really nice
to have a home-cooked meal that i can
make myself without having to think
about what ingredients i'll need and yes
i'm always a big fan with some balsamic
fig sirloin
it's one of the recipes it's good it's
got all the flavor palette that you need
i need it
easily change your delivery days or food
preferences and skip a week whenever you
need
keep your fridge stocked by adding extra
proteins or sides like garlic bread to
your weekly order you get some weeks
your appetite is more jabba than yoda
let's be honest
hella fresh offers more delicious
options every week to help you break out
of your recipe right and try new things
there's something for everyone including
low calorie vegetarian and kid friendly
recipes
hellofresh delivers fresh high quality
pre-portioned ingredients
so you can make meals that are delicious
and nutritious here's what you got to do
just go to hellofresh.com
bigquestion8080 and use the code
bigquestion80 to get a total of eighty
dollars off your first month
including free shipping on your first
box additional restrictions apply please
visit hellofresh.com for more details
okay we are now gonna move on to some
bite size questions that i'm gonna
answer
jovin's got them for me uh yes we got
some bite-sized questions
and the first one's coming from the new
rockstars discord we have civilian
that asks how much webbing can sam
raimi spider-man use before peter needs
to refill
so specifically the sam raimi spider-man
because you know he had it
right there in the wrist yeah he had the
organic uh web shooters
yeah it's an interesting question right
because like in the comics and pretty
much every other version of spider-man
that's not sam raimi it comes out of
the app like machine apparatuses that he
built even the amazing spider-man we see
him like kind of play with the tech
behind it
so if he doesn't need to refill it how
does he refill it what do you have to do
by eating
wrestling drinking it's hard to know
because really nowhere during the actual
run time or anywhere in the scripts of
the sam raimi films is the actual
biology of the wrist web shooters
explained other than
there was that one subplot in spider-man
2 where he like loses his webbing when
he's
you know getting beaten down and he has
all these mental stresses so it's kind
of linked to that
but life is tough and i can't shoot
anymore
well we were able to find this one
insert in the official handbook of the
marvel universe spider-man back in black
released in march 2007
obviously in in uh joining the the third
spider-man film with tim mcguire there
was this one section that talked about
peter's abilities and it says and i
quote
peter can produce silk from glands
within his forearms
limited by his body's health and
nutrition these organic webs have many
similar properties to the artificial
webbing
though they require a week to decay
rather than decomposing within two hours
which i think is such a bizarre
statement because it acknowledges that
the version in the same rabies movies is
wrong
because it's wrong yeah wrong and it
says that it has to
decay over the course of a week the
whole point is that the webbing
dissolves
within two hours enough time for the
cops to catch up to the webbed up
criminals if it takes a week
all over new york city you just have
this gross sticky goo that's everywhere
could you imagine you had uh in
homecoming donald glover's characters
like holding on to like his trunk for an
entire
week like can someone bring me a burger
or something why did i have to park on
the lowest level
one week later
but anyway in the toby verse this would
uh suggest that peter does need to
like stay in shape eat healthy get a
good night's rest
in order to continue to produce organic
webbing at the rate he does
that corresponds to what we saw in
spider-man 2. he wasn't sleeping well
he he wasn't eating well when you have
uh mental stresses you're not taking
care of yourself
and there's like some uh real body
comparisons
that are affected by you know nutrition
and even
the way you think so you know if other
liquids in your body can't perform
uh correctly based if you're not feeling
it in your head then you know the
webbing
is probably just the same you're going
somewhere gross with this jovan i can
feel it
you know it is the human body and it is
natural
and it's there we shall find our answers
but we still feel shame over it at the
end of the day
that's so much shame that's the best
answer i got for you civilian all right
uh and also coming from our discord
we've got uh on the penta ooh
i'm saying that wrong i believe it is uh
oon pantaloon
i who can produce the most amount of
heat
with their powers in the marvel universe
so who is
the hottest character well the hottest
character
obviously agent bill coulson but that's
a separate version of hot
ouch ouch ouch well okay so i broke it
down to our top three
because there's a lot of um uh fire
starters there's sunspot there's human
torch there's there's
a bunch of people have similar powers so
human torch johnny storm clocks in at
number three
extremely hot he can create the nova
level burst
of a million degrees fahrenheit but
that's a burst and when he bursts like
that his powers are kind of extinguished
temporarily he's got to recharge
so he just comes in at number three much
like spider-man's glam
much like his glitch joven children's
getting gross together
the number two hottest character is nova
frankie ray
who is similar to the human torch uh but
as the herald to galactus
she's infused with his cosmic energies
allowing her to use that stellar fire
more consistently but the number one
hottest character
in the marvel universe is our man ghost
rider he is by far the hottest
because it's uh incalculable he is made
of hell fire
it's almost infinitely hot he's got the
move the pen and stare
that can incinerate and mutilate his
enemies souls and if your heat is
metaphysically hot
my friend you are the hottest character
uh so what burns at a higher temperature
uh
adamantium or a human soul that's a
it's um that's i mean the human soul it
depends on how good your soul is like my
human soul probably has a very low
um
big question it's it's more like a
question for the podcast
the deep question the real question
uh yeah i mean some of us have souls
that are bitter and are
you know kindling that the grim reaper
is just waiting
to throw in the bonfire some people
souls uh are so hard to burn they just
float right up to heaven
and that's them and if your ghostwriter
your piss burns
so oh yeah burns all the time and not
because of
never mind you won't go that way well uh
we have time for one final boss
scraps questions and staying on the
theme of why
the mandalorians and the mandalorian
have to wear their helmet all the time
our question this week is what is the
fashion faux pas you once tried to pull
off thinking it was a good idea
but was actually a huge mistake oh
i'm so glad that i don't have a picture
to accompany this answer
but the matrix reloaded came out
about the same time i was a freshman in
high school and you know walking through
that hot topic i 100
spent 80 dollars on a shiny matrix
trench coat and i wore it on ironically
[Music]
oh no i mean the matrix made it kind of
hard to walk around high school with the
trench coat because that's
they were thinking that you know the
columbine guys were kind of yeah
the the comparison there was bad also
unfortunately when i was younger it's
not as bad now
but when i was younger i actually
suffered from photophobia which is does
not mean i'm afraid of light it's an
intolerance to light
so whether it was if it was really
bright outside or if it was really
bright in a classroom i couldn't see
some colors on a white board so i had to
wear sunglasses not
only like all the time but and why i
thought
i could do that with a trench coat not
ideas bad ideas it is
the cringiest moment in my life oh boy
yeah so i went through um uh kind of a
growth spurt when i
got my first job because i my first job
was working as a
like a page where i was working
part-time on studio lots escorting
audiences and then
i got a job as a pa on a talk show which
had craft
service which once you become full-time
craft service
is a lifesaver that's where you stock up
on all your meals during the day
and i gained what um pas who got
full-time jobs on the show called
the full-time 15. uh and i uh
i gained about 15 pounds just because i
would get a cup full of those
kirkland chocolate covered almonds and i
would take them home and munch on them
all all night
uh yeah i got i could taste that memory
oh yeah oh it's a great one
um but yeah so i gained a bit of weight
and i hadn't bought like new t-shirts i
had this one t-shirt
that just suddenly did not fit me right
and i you know i i needed like kind of
more support i needed a brazier and as i
was on my way out the door
to an improv show that i was doing i am
like oh this is the only
clean shirt i have right now so i'm just
i went through my laundry room like i'm
going to wear this tank top underneath
it so like it kind of like
like it's a spanx a spanx top little
space situation
they'll just hold everything in you know
and give me some shape
but as i uh i went to the green room
some of the women on my team were like
um eric come here they're like and they
turned me around and they all started
laughing and i was like what and they're
like
you're wearing a women's tank top
underneath
and it was just the incorrect cut that
just gave me a nice
curvy shape but like it made me like
more bosomy
and it was just like because the men too
much wrong shape
i don't know what it was just a cut of
it was now different and i just looked i
went in the bathroom i'm like
i do look so feminine and like i've
never looked as good in my
life but i i had to i it was even worse
i had to take it off and just
kind of just look awkward in this show
based on that faux pas did you then just
like
curse off kirkland chocolate almonds for
the rest of your life i didn't have to
cut out the kirkland chocolate cover at
all i think i just had to like
all i had to do it was like that joke in
parks and rec where
um chris pratt comes back that one
season after getting into shape for the
marvel movies
and they're like so what do you do he's
like oh i just stopped drinking beer how
much beer were you drinking
i know right probably too much with me i
was just like i
all i did was just stop taking home
candy from craft service
no more kind deals that's all i had to
do i could eat snack on candy while i
was there but
just stop taking home entire coffee cups
full of candy
home with you and then you'll be okay
that's the key that's the key that's all
you got to do
i mean i i don't think i ever lost that
way to just stop to the growth
uh well that is our show this week jovin
thanks so much for breaking down all
that mandalorian history and the
influences
i opened up my scalp there and just
dumped the information that was there so
i i hope i didn't bore you
too much with you know uh samurai lore
oh no
we we appreciated your lucy lou samurai
sword cut brain juice it was
oh delicious it's always great to chat
with you always love having you here man
and for those of you watching a reminder
that you can join our official discord
by coming to patreon at
patreon.comrockstars where you can chat
with us submit your big questions both
of the our bite size questions were from
uh some people that we're big fans of on
our discord
and that's where we can see your
questions first you can also send them
to us
on twitter uh using the hashtag
bigquestion we'll also see it there
eventually but we're gonna be checking
discord first
you can get an audio version of the show
by subscribing to the new rockstars big
question wherever you get your podcasts
follow me at ea boss follow joven at the
jovenshire
and uh follow new rockstars and socials
and subscribe here on youtube to get too
much information on all the stuff you
care about
see you next time thanks sherman bye
guys bye
[Music]
foreign